[Music]
lady Gaga is baring it all stripping
down for paper magazines transformation
issue posing nude in one of two covers
inside the mag mother monster opens up
about what it was like and dancing
through chronic pain in order to write
and record songs for her upcoming sixth
studio album chromatic ax Gaga who
suffers from fibromyalgia says that
while recording the album she couldn't
get off the couch because her pain was
so extreme but essentially it's
neuropathic pain my brain gets stressed
my body hurts I'm angry at my body angry
at my condition angry that when I'm
stressed my body hurts you have to
radically accept that you're not going
to feel well every day maybe a little
bit last month Gaga released her first
solo single in three years
stupid love ahead of her album drop on
April 10th
oh I would like to put out music that a
big chunk of the world will hear and it
will become a part of their daily lives
and make them happy every single day the
triple-threat recently opened up about
all things chromatic ax on new music
daily with Zane Lowe on Apple music I'd
love to collapse as many of those as
possible
for now the corona virus pandemic is not
stopping Gaga's album but she is doing
her part to keep others safe she posted
on Instagram quote I wish I could see my
parents and grandmas right now but it's
much safer to not so I don't get them
sick in case I have it I'm hanging at
home with my dogs I love you world and
we'll all get through this trust me
I talked to God she said we're gonna be
okay
[Music]